Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome
to Tears of Blood
Now, if there ever was a horror game with
with a more horror game name than Tears of Blood
I would like to be told what that is
Five Nights at Fron Boys
Oh
Oh okay, alright
Hello!
Why are you thrusting your hands through that lady?
Eh heh, tha- that sounds out of context very bad, but
in context it's, well, I mean it's not good
but I'm just gonna meander over this way
'cuse me
Oh, all the younglings learning
Always good to see
Also, why is everything so slightly creepy?
And why am I here?
And why are there showers? An-
What are you- what are you talking about YouTube?
Whachu talkin' about the YouTube?
And uh- why does my body keep thrusting itself towards the camera?
Again, doesn't sound good in context, but alright, I can't go there
Hoodly doo! Imma skadoodly doo over my way here to the cafeteria, I suppose?
Is there something here I'm supposed to get?
Is there something here I'm supposed to do?
Oh! Locked! Great!
Do I need to find a key for that?
Do I need to find my way into the classroom with all the kids?
Nope!
Oh yes, there we go
Hello- ohhhh- oh good we're on dune!
I thought we were on Earth for a second
I like the giant boob hill over there, that's awfully nice
Oh! Where are we going?
To hell?
I hope it's- ohh God
Hi?
Hello?
Why you crying?
What's goin' on?
Alrightly then, Imma meander over this way
Not gonna bother you
Locked?! Good!
Gracious- oh!
I don't like the old timey music goin' on over there
and something's wrong with this pool
Imma dive in and check
Oh, locked! I need to find a key, I think
I'm not a hundred percent sure about that one, but maybe
Ooh, this has been bashed down, I wonder if there's anything fun happening over here
Helloo? Oh! A key! Goody!
Okay, well, I got a key and I know what that means
But Imma sprint as fast as I can over here through the school I thought I knew
Ah, good, could we loop one more on the planet of dune and boob hill?
Ohhh! It's Mount Boob, I'm sorry, I pronounced that wrong
Hi! Okay, oh
*growling*
Alrighty then
Oh! *Mark giggles*
That was a sweet kick!
You caught me off guard!
Hey, you're taller than him! Beat him up!
Ow, oh
I dunno what that- oh, you're dead apparently
Oh no!
And now it's gonna kill meee!
OH MY GOOOOOOOD!
Oh, well, alright, I guess I'm gonna go here then
Is it comin' after me? I can't even tell
Good thing I'm goo- so good at moonwalking, I could moonwalk away from that
Uhh- oh! Hi- Hi!
Hello!
Oh police officers! I thought you were just creepy people standing in the middle of the hallway!
Oh yeah, I dunno how to explain this one, she got drop kicked
Huh, her skull's caved in from a sweet drop kick to the face
Let's skedaddle over this- oh
HEY!
Fucking, fuck you, don't DO that, I'm not prepared!
Can I go in the showers? I dunno- whoa, what are you doing over there?
Why you just staring at that blood?
Do you really need to be on your hands and knees looking that closely at blood?
So why was there blood over there? I don't remember- whoa, I can't see in here
Well, Imma assume that I don't need to go into the black void of the pool
So Imma continue on the way I know I should go
which is this way
Mr. Director, why won't you open your door?
Also, why am I here when there's police here?
Why am I just a meandering, observer in this universe of death?
Oh
Hello?
I need to find a key
Do I? Do I really?
I bet it's back in the pool, the black oblivion that I didn't want to go into
I bet that's the one, unless it's in here somewhere
Okay, oh great, this is my flashlight on!
Great, okay so, there's gotta be some over here
Definitely not in there
Ooh, what's this?
Nope!
That's a big 'ol negative on that one
Alright
Have you seen a key?
Nah, you keep looking in that pool of blood, I'll eventually get back to it
Key?
Anybody got a key?
Ooh! I found a key!
Hey! Everybody! I found a key!
It's probably vital to the investigation that you are pulling
Alright, sure okay, Imma go over here
to wherever the back kitchen leads to
cause I'm sure that's gonna help me escape this hellhole.
Sure do love being trapped in hellholes
Boink! Hello!
Who's back here?
Yes?
This is-  Ooooh! An elevator!
Oh! To turn on-
To turn ON the elevator!
That's not a- that is not an elevator
that's a hole in the ground
You wouldn't know the difference between an elevator and your ass and a hole in the ground
you son of a bitch
But I'm gonna go jump in that hole
and see where it leads me
Cops, don't worry about me
I'm about to jump down a hole
Okay! We love you!
Thanks, what friendly police officers!
Ehhhh, okay
Oh! Ah!
Where- Where am I-
Where- Where am I?
Where am I- Oh! I saw a burning cross
Okay...
Ah! Good!
The land of thorns and inverted shadows
Oh good..
Alrighty then...
Oh, why am I here?
Why am I here?
What have you got in store for me?
I'm- I'm not sure if it's creepy or cool, but-
kinda cool?
Kinda cool-py?
Is that what we're gonna call it?
Oh! There's that burning cross I saw so much!
Oh, someone's on it...
Ahh
Is that that drop kick lady?
Oh she man-she had a rough time in this neighborhood
uh
OH
Am I going to jump?
Why am I going to jump-OOoh
I have to jump now.
OH NO
DON'T SLAP ME!!!
NOT A SWEET DROP KICK- uuAHHuh
ok
alright then that seems like thorns
Oh oooh uh ah eh uwah oh eh
AYE AYE AYE AYE AYE
HEY
NO
NONE OF THAT
HEY
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOUR DOING?
HUH?
You doin the dance?
I don't want any
don't want any of that
you stay away from me
ew
gross
cooties
ew
NO
DON'T CUT OFF MY ESCAPE ROUTE
alright
EUAH
It's locked, I gotta find a kEuh (key)
I gotta find one of those sweet kEuhS (keys) before he GETS me.
Oh, open that UWAH I GOT STOOK (stuck)
k
open that up
now don't STOOK (stuck) me
HEYUAHH WHY WHY
WHY DID YOU BLOOD ME?
WHY DID YOU BLOOD THOSE (unintelligible)
How could you be blooding so much around here?
UUGH
Man, your drop kick has a lot more range than I suspected
Alright yea yea that's right go in the pool
AHH
THAT WAS A FAAAST
WoAh hey that was a fast
hey don't do none of that
None of that is no good
All of that is no good
UWAH HEY FUCKING
FUCK
WHY
Why now? Why now did you suddenly get jumpscary?
Gotta key, I found THREE KEYS
*bang*
IEEEIEEEIEEEIEEEEIEEEEE
AYIEEEIEEEIEEE aww its locked
oh its looked (locked)
Well I don't know where to go for this
*rumble*
(le surprised markimoo)
hi
excuse you-OOH THATS erALRIGHTY THEN (unintelligible mark noices)
*bang*
UWAH HEY THAT ONE
ok well this is open
well now its closed
Is it open or closed?
I don't know
You're hot then you're cold, you're yes then you're no (Mark is Katy Perry lmao)
You're open then you're closed THERES NO ELEVATOR (I don't remember those lyrics in that song Mark)
THAT IS NOT AN ELEVATOR
THAT IS THE OPPOSITE OF AN ELEVATOR
oh boy
oh boy oh boingo bongo
OH BINGO BONGO
ok
DON'T BLOOD ME
I DON'T WANNA BE BLOODED
EUAHH~
I can barely see through all the flickering
Oh I'm safe and sound
nonoNONONO NONE OF THIS
NO DROP KICKS IN HERE~
oh yea you meander all slowly
don't worry
ha HA HAHA
get rekt BITCH
UUUHHH
gotta check the ceilings for monsters
or drop kicks
HEY FUCKING DROP KICK
GODDAMNIT
You kick dropped me
oh
fuck
well
it was all just a drem (dream)
It was all one of those-Uh oh
Honey!
(girl in game): Good morning!
oh~
It IS a good morning- ok good bye then *laughing*
*more laughing*
*even more laughing*
That was intentionally hilarious but that WAS hilarious
alright, It was this guys first game or girl
It was this persons first game
That was actually not that bad
(le markimoo rambling about the word "actually")
That was not that bad
It was uh-It was pretty good it had a lot of flaws, it had a lot of things that I laughed at
But honestly, no there was some potential here
It was just a little bit crude but I could see how he had executed a few concepts here
And it wasn't, it wasn't too bad
So I liked it
So, Thank you for making it, uh, and everybody who watched it let me know what you thought about it in the comments below
And thanks for watching. If you wanna play it for yourself,
Check out the link in the description
So thanks again for watching, and as always
I will see YOU in the next video BUH BYEEEE!!
*le marks amazing outro*